we got a really funny voicemail um
sam cedar host of the majority report
and i were in
what as far as i knew was like a fake
feud over youtube
subscribers but really it's all about
just growing independent media
here's a caller who thought the feud was
real
and doesn't like it and also came up
with a really funny metaphor
let's listen to it yeah i just wanted to
leave a message and
let you know something cause i heard you
say
the other day or a couple weeks ago on
your show
that uh or you were you were giving your
uh ragging on sam cedar for having more
subscribers than him
sorry um and
i just thought it was weird because it's
like well i'm i subscribed it
hit this hand cedar and i subscribed to
you so
i mean like turns out i i i guess you
guys are like feuding over it so like
to me it's like two bald men fighting
over a comb i i love that
two bald men fighting over a comb but i
every once in a while you know i had i
had a funny conversation with uh
with sam when this was all going on when
we were trying to get to a million
subscribers on youtube and so was he
and i said you know the reason that
every time i talk about it i say by the
way guys this is a joke
is because there are people in the
audience who think that this is serious
and uh i don't remember sam's response i
don't know if he was incredulous or what
was
or maybe he said don't worry about that
it's funnier that some people think it's
real
um i still get emails from people saying
david i think it's really disrespectful
what you're saying about sam cedar and
you know
the left shouldn't be in fighting it's
just a joke guys it's just a joke
we got to a million sam got to a million
all is good independent progressive
media is growing
and it's a great thing and we're excited
about all of it and it's all
a a fantastic thing and by the way we
are now
our target now is 1.5
million youtube subscribers i know that
it seems like just yesterday we were
getting to one million it was actually
three three months ago we are now almost
at 1.3
million subscribers and it would be
nuts if within 2021 we were able to get
to 1.5 million subscribers but
that's for a future fake feud it's not
for right now
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the georgia secretary of state
has launched an investigation into
donald trump's
so-called perfect phone call asking for
11 000 votes
we will talk about that a judge has
ruled that
recreational cannabis in south dakota
is unconstitutional as written in the
measure that was recently
up for for vote there and we also have
found out i don't know how many of you
saw this but there was a streaker in the
super bowl on sunday night
apparently that was a planted streaker
by a youtuber i'm going to talk about
the implications of this the importance
and uh i actually i want to talk a
little bit about the policy
that many network networks have of uh
swinging the camera away cutting away
from streakers so as not to encourage
them
by uh promoting what they're doing and
showing what they're doing
i want to talk about whether that's
effective and whether there might be
other ways to
uh to to deal with it so all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
and of course you get instant access to
the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
and live all week including
today with donald trump's second
impeachment trial we will be live on
youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me i believe you
will
um and we will see uh what we get from
that i believe it
will be an illuminating experience and a
frustrating one
i will see you then